okay so the last story of today so a
couple of months ago there was a lady
that went viral on Twitter
she was on an airplane and had a freak
out because she saw a quote-unquote
non-living entity something like that so
here's the video that initially went
viral
I'm telling you you need to [__] off and
there's a reason why I'm getting the
[__] off and everyone
leave it or they cannot believe it I
don't give
but I am telling
tally right now that mother
mother that [__] back there is
not real
and you can sit on this plane and you
can [__] die with him or not I'm not
going to
so you know we got this chick
screaming about how some guy on the
plane isn't real now this woman went
radio silent for three weeks and all of
the conservatives on Twitter wanted to
know what happened like everybody's
asking all these questions like what
what did this lady see so you know
additional footage comes out
and yeah this is her after if you don't
leave you'll be uh under arrest or
criminal trespass
this is your warning right here
okay
am I leaving
what are you talking about ma'am if you
don't leave right now if you could be
under arrest for criminal trespass
let's go
what about slight leaves
do not let that plate leave
being dead serious do not let that
slightly
now after three weeks of Silence
she finally comes forward they found out
this lady is a marketing director
and
you know there's a lot of conspiracy
theories they're kind of conjuring but
now she comes forward and issues a
public apology
as you know I
have been unwilling to speak on the
viral video but I do finally feel that
it's time
first and foremost I want to
take full accountability for my actions
they were completely unacceptable
distressed or not I should have been I
should have been in control of my
emotions and
that was not the case
my use of profanity was completely
unnecessary
and I want to apologize to everyone on
that plane especially those that had
children aboard
can imagine going through that and
trying to explain to your kid what in
the world just happened
we all have our bad moments
um some far worse than others and mine
happened to be caught on camera for the
whole world to see multiple times
sorry trying not to sound like Minnie
Mouse
well it has been really comical for
everyone and I have highly enjoyed so
many of the means
on the flip side it is very invasive and
unkind
and I don't know what I would do without
the love and support of my friends and
family
they are loyal to a fault and I don't
know what I did to deserve them
um
sorry y'all
I hope that I can use this experience
and do a little bit of good in the world
and that is what I intend to do
I hope that you guys can accept my
apology and I can begin to move on with
my life
so now the internet
has been set Ablaze
Because the Internet does not believe
that this is the same woman who actually
believes this is the crazy plain lady
Tiffany Gomez speaking out who the f are
they trying to kid so that's like the
side by side we got there
I okay my first thought was this is how
[__] look before and after my show
like like on the left that's what they
look like here and on the right is after
they take pictures on this couch and
like Photoshop them
that was that was what I was thinking
but
like to me it kind of looks like an
internet filter but you know a lot of
people are saying that this was
orchestrated to distract us from what's
going on in Hawaii right now so what I
think um is going on in Hawaii is
exactly what's going on in Alberta other
land grabs Hawaii is very small it has a
small amount of land available
especially for Millionaires and
billionaires that have houses in these
areas that want to keep building so the
easiest way instead of offering people
money for their homes is to just burn
the entire place down and pretty much
burn people out of their area they did
that in Alberta here to try and get
people into 15-minute cities and I'm
pretty sure that's what they're doing in
Maui now why am I saying that well I did
a video on the Epstein flight log list
exposed everybody that was on the
flights and I also put up uh classified
documents that were from the Gillian
Maxwell court case and then I even put
up her a flight log so not just
um
Epstein's flight logs but her flight
logs that were released in court as well
people went absolutely wild the video
went super viral
um some people were super mad at me
because their movie stars were on like
on Epstein Island but if you look at the
correlation of the people who were on
Epstein Island and the people who own
houses on Maui you're gonna see a huge
correlation and these people do not stop
at at anything and they want more land
so they can keep building their entire
houses bigger now the only reason I know
this is I went to Hawaii I think 13
years ago and talking to the locals they
were all complaining about the same
thing over development developers coming
in and trying to take homes of regular
people for way under the asking price
and then building like multi-million
dollar or billion dollar
um hotels homes on that land
so what people started doing is they
won't take any offer from any developer
so what's another way of getting people
off of their land is to burn it Scorch
it or make it literally non-livable on
and I think that's what's happening in
Hawaii whether it was done on purpose
with DW's or you know other forms of
silent weapons or if it was done by one
of these MPC crazy people who believe in
global warming yet they don't really
understand the billionaires and the
millionaires are still taking private
jets they have cruise ship sized private
yachts they're not stopping eating me
they're not stopping flying around the
world so I mean you know there's a bunch
of people out there that will believe
the agenda and then try and push it but
I think this is a lot deeper kind of
like in Alberta and I truly feel for the
people in Hawaii stay strong come
together as a community like we did here
in Alberta and really try and help each
other out
um start a GoFundMe page in case your
insurance company these don't really
come through with you and I hope that we
can all kind of stick together and hope
and pray for Hawaii right now yeah so
I Here's my thought I don't really know
about the whole conspiracy theories but
I've seen a bunch of different like
takes on Twitter but that I would say
that's like the sum of what I've seen
um I do think it was the same lady just
with a filter on you don't you know
[__] and filters right I mean like we
love our filters
um like sometimes after the show some
girls will take selfies with me and the
filters on and I'm like oh my gosh I
look like a different lady
um but
yeah I don't I don't know I
I'm hesitant to say that it's like a a
psyop but I I haven't ruled it out
completely so I guess it'll be
interesting to see the updates in this
development and I will keep you guys
posted
but yeah that's um this week's craziness
treachery debauchery and let me know
what you want me to cover next if you
guys have any submissions make sure you
submit them to my Instagram just
probably things one like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time